it's time for drew's news let's hop onto
the good news horse and giddy up into
the good news
and with me at the desk is my favorite
co-pilot aka
stall mate
roxy
[Applause]
my daughters and i pass a horse they
look at me because they like me to say
this horsey
anyhow what do you think is her
impression of yay or a name
okay first step two of our favorite love
birds i mean i know it's happening it's
everywhere i'm so happy for them people
reports the machine gun kelly were
proposed to none other than his love
megan fox
we love this
and
you know
machine gun kelly came on this show and
really did us a solid by saying hey i
just want to come here and like peel
back the layers and keep it real and we
love him so much for it
and um
he talked about megan and you know how
she calms him
and the beautiful way she handles him
supports him loves him
and here they are
official i was so sweet the way he
talked about her and i love their
relationship and the fact that you know
they put a ring on it it's so sweet they
did celebrate in a very interesting way
though did you hear yeah tell me what it
said because i read it too but i want to
know your take rossie well all i know is
that it said that after the proposal
that they
drank each other's blood
which i think is you know uh if i good
for you i'm very happy would you have
you
what do you
not for me i'm
i'm more of like a chocolate milk kind
of guy
i don't know you don't want wellies uh
blood you'd rather have a yoo-hoo
ding-dong i'll take it you could have
had a v8
could have had to be yeah totally you
know what's weird is the way i read it
actually was like a joke i took it as a
like a cutie wink like we're all giving
you something to talk about we're just
messing with you okay i don't know but
you never know here's what i want to say
what is i'm very happy for them i'm
happy for people who find they're
like-minded people in the world that
make them feel better about life and
themselves
this is romantic i applaud them i'm
happy for them this is great news
absolutely we love when people find love
celebrate love
uh well we do have another chapter uh
another kind of
love story you know we're celebrating
these two together but some people
love runs out and cnn reports jason
momoa and lisa bonnet have announced
that they're parting ways uh but they
did it in a lovely way uh jason posted
this message on instagram saying the
love does carry on and it evolves but
they're announcing this publicly so they
can move on with dignity and honesty
jason and lisa say they've devote
they're devoted to their children uh
that they share together we wish them
the best i thought it was sort of
beautiful the way that they did it you
know do you remember when gwyneth and
chris martin had that conscious
uncoupling and sort of showed that there
was a way where you could break up and
remain friends you've been able to do it
it's not easy but it's so worth it don't
you think
yeah i you know it's funny um gwyneth
i've talked to her about this not to
name drop but i really wanted to
understand conscious uncoupling was
actually something that her and chris
had studied there is
it wasn't a term they made up
um so yes i think there absolutely is a
way um in which to go about
things and we talk about people and
humans are just trying to do their best
and figure things out and put one foot
in front of the other and it isn't what
any part of society or any onlookers
want for them this is their journey
and it's hard to talk about and i have
to tell you having been on
both sides of it now here i am at a desk
discussing people's business i've been
on the side of it where i haven't had
the privilege of privacy because my job
does not come with that
it's something you sign up for and
anyone who complains about it didn't
look at the fine print of the contract
of you get to live this really amazing
life but these are the things that come
with it and everything has a polarity
and a double-sided coin so when these
things happen they are painful and
awkward and you try to handle them to
the best of your ability
and i just go back to the human aspect
that when there is good or difficult
it's just another human being trying to
put one foot in front of the other yeah
and i think they did it really
beautifully yes and it's a good example
to all of us and you know we've all sort
of been there when you go through a
breakup and you have to tell the whole
family but imagine if your whole family
was the entire world and they all had an
opinion about it so i thought they did
it in a very loving way and i wish them
nothing but the best right that's all we
can do yeah absolutely
all right well next up we've got some
new year's inspo from lady oh
oprah even oprah likes to reset her diet
to kick off the year i love that she's
taken us on her journey of health and
wellness her entire life totally and by
the way some people are on that journey
their whole life the entire life ups and
downs and we've been there for oprah
hello i always say i could be a weight
detective because every time i lose it i
seem to find it again and we i think
what i love about oprah she's been so
honest about this from the get right i
am an absolute quintessential fluctuate
i like one minute i'm good and the next
minute i'm back on the thing and i'm up
and i'm down so i always relate and
appreciate that she's so honest about
her journey so insider reports that
oprah posted this video of herself
throwing out gayle king's leftover
birthday cake check this out
let today be our day
one okay
goodbye bananas foster cake
and oh yeah don't forget to hydrate
okay
can i just say that that was a pretty
dense cake did you hear how that hit the
bottom of the garbage can that was
what was in that cake well i texted gail
and i got a response so i was like do
you have a comment for this i'm dying to
know and she said i wish i had known she
was going to throw it away because i
would have brought it home with me
it was one of the best cakes i've ever
tasted the chef was amazing it was her
favorite it was a bananas foster cake oh
yum so
gail would have taken the other half
and i would have eaten it with her if i
could
i understand what you know you when
something's in the house i if it's one
of the things i love i cannot resist it
so it's like don't come in the house but
oprah she should have brought it out to
the front yard to the neighbors and like
you get some cake you get some cake you
get some cake she just grew in the
garbage can by the way does anyone
remember when miranda and sex in the
city has to pour the dish soap on her
brownies
like literally i i i understand and i'm
not a food waster and i'm totally
sensitive to the subject but every once
in a while you've got to take a measure
to stop yourself from motorboating the
food in your kitchen exactly anyway oh
my god moving on all right well uh we're
going to get astrological for just a
second do you mind if we do uh no i know
you love this well the new york post
published their predictions for which
celebrities are going to have the best
2022 ever according to what the stars
say you want to know who made the list
rihanna yeah she's going to have a whole
new era of professional and and personal
growth they say and your favorite uh
robert pattinson our pats they say with
a powerful eclipse near his birthday on
may 13th he's going to be fired up to
reach new heights and then what about
this tom holland we love tom hall oh my
god i love him so much you know he's
playing fred astaire yeah in a movie and
i'm just this one i it can't come fast
enough i mean by the way you don't have
to be
merlin to figure out rihanna's going to
have great years every year is a great
year for rihanna i know because she's
she she just likes to work work work
work yeah she does
tom holland is going to have a great
year they say you know who else is going
to have a great year who drew barrymore
no yeah they did they mentioned you in
here
do you want to know what the stars hold
for you
they say 2022 is going to be a golden
year for you drew you've got major new
beginnings for you this year with lots
of luck particularly around media and
new markets and your words and ideas
will impact people mentally and
spiritual as long
as you stay true to yourself
okay well i feel confident in that i've
never been able to shake me in 40 almost
seven years so uh-huh i think i think um
i think that's safe
i love that it says in media like look
at this um we're on the cover of the
bayside times today and as you can see
[Applause]
magazines newspapers periodical
and um so
here i am in the new york state bayside
times on the cover like you have no idea
what an honor this is for me thank you
for i think you're making the astrology
predictions come true right now thank
you thank you
[Music]
you